shirt day or in honor of the birthday of
Martin Luther King on January 15th and
as I was thinking about this and
thinking about the impact this pandemic
has had on racialized populations I
thought a lot about some of the the wise
words that Martin Luther King spoke and
one of the things he said is that
Darkness cannot drive out Darkness only
light can do that and hate cannot drive
out hate only love can do that and I
think about driving out that darkness
and how we are emerging from this last
three years of this pandemic
so today I'm going to give an update on
where we are in this respiratory season
and to address some of the emerging
issues and questions that have come up
in the last few weeks particularly
around the new sub-variants of Omicron
which I know many people are worried
about concerns around surges in other
parts of the globe and particularly
China and the impacts we are seeing of
covid but also importantly as we've seen
through this last few months RSV and
influenza and many other respiratory
viruses that are causing illness and as
we've seen over this last month some of
the gastrointestinal viruses especially
norovirus which we call Winter vomiting
disease which I'm sure some people in
this room have experienced in this last
few weeks as well
I want to start by acknowledging that it
has been yet another challenging time
across BC and across Canada over this
holiday period not just because of the
pandemic but also impacts that we've
seen of weather that made this another
difficult season and in many cases kept
us away from loved ones for yet another
year but I also want to thank everyone
here in British Columbia who the
precautions that we needed to take over
the holidays to keep themselves their
loved ones and their communities safe
everything from getting your flu shot to
skipping those holiday parties if you
weren't feeling well to taking advantage
of things like playing outside in the
snow and finding ways to overcome those
forces that kept us apart with the new
tools that we've learned over this last
few years all of your efforts have made
a difference
in particular I want to thank all of
those who answered our call in November
and December and took time over with
their busy holiday schedules to get
vaccinated both for covid and that all
important bivalent booster and also for
influenza this has made a tremendous
difference at ensuring we could manage
and protecting those around us as well
as ourselves
so many people in BC came together to
support our health care System we know
that this pandemic has exposed the
long-term strains on our Health Care
system and on the people working within
it
I of course I know that many people
unfortunately did get sick over the
holidays which put a damper on many of
our plans
but we found ways to celebrate
regardless in ways that we have learned
in this past three years
in addition to many different
respiratory viruses over those last few
weeks we've also seen a bit of norovirus
which has started to cause impacts both
in our communities but also in some of
our health care settings and while we're
out of the holiday season we're still
very much in respiratory season
so today I'm going to give an update on
where we're at with that what we're
seeing and what a look ahead at what may
happen in the coming weeks to understand
where we're at with all of these
respiratory viruses we in public health
have many different sources of data that
we look at sometimes daily but also
weekly and we post many of these on the
bccdc website and it is having these
many sources of data that fill in this
full picture so no one thing tells us
the whole story it is all of these
measures together that help us
understand are things going up or down
where are we seeing the pressure points
in certain parts of the provinces what
are we seeing with different things so
I'm going to talk a little bit about
each of these different measures one of
the most important ones we continue
people continue to be tested for
covid-19 and in our Laboratories now
when somebody gets a test for covet
because of respiratory illness we also
test for rrsv for influenza A influenza
B and para influenza we have one test
that can do all of those and about a
thousand people a day on average
have been getting a PCR test because
they have a respiratory illness and they
are either in the emergency department a
clinic a doctor sends them to the lab
and as I mentioned we do these Multiplex
PCR tests so we can see what proportion
the test positive for these different
respiratory viruses that's one of the
things that helps us understand what's
causing illness across the province so
these are what we call medically
necessary tests we don't just test
everybody we test you when you need to
have a test because it makes a
difference for your medical treatment
so these are people who have serious
enough illness that they seek medical
attention or people at risk of more
severe illness from either covet or
influenza and are eligible for
treatments things like paxilovid or also
tamifier for influenza
a second most more important other
important source of information is data
on people in hospital in ICU and we have
that data for covet it's taken a long
time to get that that's not something
that we historically had for every other
respiratory virus but we've now added
this year more information on people in
hospital with influenza with RSV as well
and that gives us a sense of is this
going up or down what what is causing
most severe illness that's leading
people to be in hospital or in ICU we
also need to remember that our behaviors
have changed over the course of the
pandemic we're doing a lot more testing
for Respiratory viruses than we ever did
before so we can't compare necessarily
to influenza seasons and RSV Seasons
that we had prior to this pandemic
a third a source of data that we monitor
that we put in place to help us
understand this puzzle is outbreaks so
we look at outbreaks that are in
healthcare facilities including acute
care facilities and long-term care homes
and those again are reported from
different parts of the province and that
helps us understand spread in
communities and impact on on these most
vulnerable settings
we also have a well-established what we
call Sentinel provider surveillance
Network and so the spsn that's been
started at the bccdc way back in the
early 2000s and it is a way of that
we've been using to help us understand
people who go to see a physician or a
nurse practitioner for an influenza-like
illness and so we follow physician
buildings for that and that's on the
bccdc website that's that respiratory
illness
and those people who participate in this
they do a swab and somebody who they
think has influenza or covid or RSV and
we test those in the lab for all of
those pathogens and we do hold genome
sequencing on those so I'll talk about
that in a minute so that's really
important that's been around for many
years that gives us a sense of when
influenza-like illness we call it is in
different parts of the province so we
can break it down by health authority
and geography as well
so along with these sources of data
we've expanded the the work that we've
done with whole genome sequencing which
is kind of new and exciting and we had
the expertise at the bccdc and you saw
very early on in this pandemic we were
doing samples that helped us understand
where the viruses were coming from where
covet was coming from because we could
link them by the genetic code we've
expanded that program and the public
health Lab at bccdc has is now testing
all of the the cases that we get from
for people at hospital with covid we're
doing whole genome sequencing on samples
of people who have tests in the
community from outbreaks and this really
gives us a sense of what strains we're
seeing in BC and if they've changed this
is something that's new globally we've
never actually had this ability to watch
a virus change in almost real time and
and that has led to some of the the
issues that we have about what's the
meaning of new subvariants and I'll talk
a bit about that in a minute
so rsrs cov2 genomic surveillance is
focused on identifying what variants are
causing more severe illness so we really
want to make sure anybody who's in
hospital particularly because of covet
but we test anybody who's been in
hospital with a coveted positive test we
do hold genome sequencing to see if
there's something that's emerging that's
causing more severe illness
and we also do it on community PCR tests
and I said and the tests from there are
Sentinel provider Network
and along with this we have the the
Wastewater surveillance that we've
started way back in 2020 and that was
built on a platform of of some work that
was done with some of the key experts at
the bccdc prior to the pandemic and
we've been able to use that expertise to
look at variants in different areas of
the province that's been in place as we
know in the Lower Mainland and that
again is posted on the dashboard of
bccdc to help us understand
regardless of who's being tested how
much virus is out there and not only
that but we now can do whole genome
sequencing on those viruses that come
from the Wastewater surveillance plants
and that tells us is there different
strains in different parts or different
variants in different parts of the
province
we've recently added just over the fall
additional testing sites in Interior
Health and Island Health and those data
are being validated it takes time to
develop you know the understanding of
the nuances of the different systems and
they will be publicly available when
they've been stabilized and validated
and I think that's likely to be sometime
in February
we're also really interestingly in BC
because we have this expertise and full
genome sequencing and the techniques of
of looking at waste water we're working
to validate whole genome sequencing for
influenza A and B and RSV and Wastewater
something that's novel it's not been
done around the country or around the
world so this will be something that
will give us a sense in the future of
what types of influenza we're seeing and
where the burden of that is and really
interesting and we have very little
information on RSV in the past so we're
we're able to we should be able to look
at that too as you also may know the
public health agency of Canada has
expanded its Wastewater surveillance and
to include YVR and we're partnering with
them to do that it's something that
we've been wanting to do for some time
not just on flights from China which you
know helps us understand what strains
are circulating there but from other
places in the world too and I think this
will be another piece that we can add to
those things that we look at to help us
understand what's happening
and what's how it's changing over time
so like I said it's like putting
together a puzzle and all the different
pieces form part of the picture so what
is it telling us
and the short the good news is it's
telling us that influenza continues to
decline following this very strong early
Peak that we saw in November and
December RSB has continued to stay high
it's now at where we would expect it to
see this time of year and it's leveling
off and covet has remained relatively
stable the past several months and I'll
just talk about these in a little bit
more detail
for so in terms of
influenza our data indicate from these
various different sources that influenze
in all age groups has steadily declined
from the peak where we saw about 27 test
positivity in in late November
um down to we're about five percent now
so with all those tests that are done
about five percent of them are positive
for uh influenza this has been a very
unusual year so it is very important to
recognize that we can't necessarily
compare this year to previous influenza
Seasons prior to the pandemic
we knew and we talked about this in
September and October that we saw a very
similar unusual pattern in Australia and
New Zealand during their influenza
season
um last their last winter
and we knew that this was a possibility
and that was one of the things that we
were planning for and I know the
minister will talk about impacts on the
health system
so we did see that very rapid increase
and thanks to many people getting
vaccinated and what we did we start to
see
decreases across age groups and
particularly in children who've been
affected by influenza as we know leading
to hospitalization in many many children
and we we know now that this is largely
because there is a whole cohort several
cohorts of children who were never
exposed to influenza because of all the
measures we had in place and
particularly the the restrictions on
travel globally influenza didn't spread
through the first two years of the
pandemic so there's people whose immune
system haven't developed that protection
that they needed
um the other thing that I think is
important is that influenza A H3N2 is
the one that's been causing most illness
and the one that's thankfully decreasing
and you know that is the the strain of
influenza that we see that most likely
causes severe illness particularly in
children who've never been exposed to it
before and in older people
and we also know that there are other
strains of influenza and we often see
later in the season that we'll see
another wave of of influenza B so we're
watching for that and so far we've not
seen a lot of it but it does tend to
happen later in the season and it tends
not to be as severe because most of us
have had some exposure to influenza B at
some point in our lives and it doesn't
change as quickly as influenza A
um the other so we're continuing to
monitor
um we have as you know put in active
surveillance to look for severe illness
in children after the pediatricians
particularly at Children's Hospital
raised the alarm with us that they were
concerned that they were hearing about
very severe illness and deaths in
children in in early December and we
have not seen any additional deaths
in beyond the the six that were
initially reported that we linked to
influenza early on in the season so
that's important and thankful
so
the other thing that I do want to
mention is because we had such an early
rapid season our Sentinel Physicians
practitioner surveillance Network we
were able to do some vaccine
Effectiveness on that and the work that
the bccdc and Dr skervonsky's team and
it showed that early estimates showed
that the protection from the vaccine
that we have right now reduces your
chances of needing to see a physician or
a nurse practitioner for influenza cuts
that risk by at least half so that's the
good news and for those who have not yet
been vaccinated it's still it's still
available and important to do that
terms of RSV respiratory Sensational
virus why we are seeing a decrease in
influenza our speed remains relatively
High although it is also leveling off
and is causing less illness in children
which is also important and good news
and it's about where we would expect it
to be at this time of year prior to the
pandemic so RSV is another one of those
respiratory viruses that when we stop
travel and we stop Gatherings and we had
all of those measures in place it didn't
circulate very easily either and now
we're going back to a more normal season
and and unfortunately for us the start
of rrsp
was at around the same time that we were
seeing this this unusual and dramatic
spike in influenza as well
so children who would normally have been
exposed over the last two years weren't
and so they didn't have that immunity
and what we're seeing is it's again a
cohort effect where there were many more
children and slightly older children who
were susceptible and of course as it
started early on and we know that that
made a tremendous impact particularly on
children's hospitals
and just to remind people that the
emergency
departments are still busy and they have
put in place measures to make sure that
we can quickly and effectively triage
children and if you need if your child
is ill and needs to be seen don't be
afraid to go to the emergency department
but also know that your child's illness
can be treated by a doctor's office a
walk-in clinic the Urgent and Primary
Care Centers or if you need immediate
medical advice you can contact Health
Link at 811
and so finally covet is the other major
one that's been added to the respiratory
viruses that we are likely to see at
least for the next number of years
and covid-19 has remained relatively
stable over the last three months
hospitalizations increased a bit at the
same time that we were seeing
hospitalizations for influenza and RSV
increase in December but are now slowly
coming back down
and we look again at the many different
sources of information and particularly
things like the Wastewater surveillance
which is not dependent on testing and it
shows a slowing and a decrease a month
across much of the Lower Mainland which
is in keeping with the same thing we're
seeing in visits to clinics in long-term
care outbreaks and in the testing data
that we have so all of these pieces
together tell us that we're slowly
decreasing
um the same thing across time and really
this is is thanks to people stepping up
and being vaccinated I can't
overestimate the the importance of
having those booster doses in
um effectively blocking the transmission
in our communities
I want to and along with that I want to
talk a minute about uh
the xbv 1.5 variant
because it's been on a lot of people's
minds over the last few weeks to date
we've had 24
confirmed cases so those are ones where
the test has been done and we've done
the whole genome sequencing that shows
it's this specific subvariant
and it's important to note that this
doesn't reflect the total number of
cases in the province this is the
surveillance data so this gives us a
sense of What proportion of the test
that we're doing the whole genome
sequences turn out to be this one and we
saw the first ones in late November
early December and we now have found a
boat it's it's up to about five or six
percent of the whole genome sequences
are this variant the most that we're
seeing here 95 percent of what is
causing illness in in the province is
still the BQ 1.1 all of these are
subvariants of over chronic and I think
that's really really important
and wild scar this xbb 1.5 has garnered
a lot of attention it Still Remains a
sub-variant of Omicron so what does that
mean
any new variant that has an advantage
spreads more easily that's what viruses
do they change to try and reproduce
themselves more quickly and if it
spreads more easily it often will
replace the ones that went before it so
each new one that spreads by definition
is the most infectious one to date and
we've seen that with
xbb 1.5 so why does it take off in some
places and not in others a lot of it has
to do with the defenses that we have in
our community
and importantly there is no evidence
that this subvariate is causing more
severe illness and there's very good
evidence that our vaccines are still
providing strong protection from serious
illness and death especially if you've
had the bivalent booster that has that
Omicron and antigen in it so you have
not yet had that then you need to get it
so we must remember that these new
strains may make us more vulnerable to
infection but they don't render us
defenseless the defenses we have built
through immunization and combinations of
vaccine immunity and infection-induced
Immunity means we have strong defenses
as a community across this province we
are no longer in the place where we
needed to take Extraordinary Measures
because everybody was susceptible and
many many people could get seriously ill
need hospital care or die
and as we talked about hospitalization
due to covid-19 is decreasing
and even though it is decreasing we know
our hospitals are stretched it's not
surprising this time of year we
traditionally experience an increase in
hospitalizations in January as people
access care after the holiday period And
it often coincides with an increase in
respiratory illnesses and usually this
is when we would start to see influenza
really taking off as well
people delaying secret seeking treatment
over the holidays because of the weather
is one of the issues or in challenges in
accessing care and again of course
surgeries ramping up again after the
holidays slow down
and also I will mention we've been
seeing norovirus so this
gastrointestinal illness causing effects
as well
so as we get back into our regular
activities following the holidays it is
important to continue to take measures
to protect ourselves and others from
respiratory viruses and other infections
first and foremost getting vaccinated
getting that booster dose if you haven't
already these boosters make a difference
if you're feeling unwell whether it's
from a respiratory virus or fever and a
rash or GI upset nausea vomiting stay
home stay away from others and
particularly avoid contact with people
who are more vulnerable to severe
illness themselves
it's so important and I say this how
many millions of times to you know
regularly wash your hands practice
proper respiratory etiquette covering
our coughs properly disposing of tissues
we can also wear masks especially in
crowded indoor spaces when there's poor
ventilation
you can wear masks for yourself for
additional protection if you're somebody
who is more at risk and for others if
you have mild symptoms of what could be
a respiratory virus or is still
recovering or have had contact with
somebody at home who's ill
I know this remains a challenging time
for people who are most vulnerable to
covet especially and these are the same
people who are more at risk for severe
illness from influenza and from other
infections too
while we know we cannot stop all
transmission of viruses even with broad
measures like masking all the time and
stopping Gatherings and travel
and we know these measures have very
important negative Health impacts too
what we do know is that having the high
rates of vaccination and hybrid immunity
that we have protects everyone
and the analogy that somebody said to me
the other day was you know would you
rather be the only person vaccinated in
your community or the only person
unvaccinated and everybody else in your
community is vaccinated
and that's an important thing to think
about because all of us being vaccinated
gives added protection for those who
don't have a strong response to vaccine
and it gives a buffer so the viruses
can't spread as easily
what we do protects those around us it
makes it harder for the virus to spread
not completely not 100 but definitely
harder and we've seen the impact of that
we know it's never going to be 100
percent so we all need to be mindful of
others who are more at risk
given space
use the tools that we have all of the
tools that we have postpone
non-essential visits if we're not
feeling well wear good fitting medical
or n95 massive you need that extra
protection
ensure people at high risks are able to
access and wear masks too and we have
been very clear about ensuring that
everybody has access to booster doses to
their flu shot and access to treatments
for both covet and influenza
so I'm just gonna
finally say you know respiratory illness
will continue and generally we start
seeing it leveling off into February and
and by March so we're not out of the
woods by any means yet
but if we all continue to do these
things to use all of our tools to be
respectful and mindful of each other we
will get out of this season in the best
shape possible
I want to thank everyone for their
continued commitment in BC to protecting
themselves their loved ones and their
communities during this respiratory
illness season another challenging time
for us as we work to emerge from this
pandemic
emerge into the light and return to
those important activities in our lives
thank you very much
thank you very much Dr Henry um and I
wanted to bring you an update
on the Emergency Operations centers
around the province and the challenges
we're facing in acute care and the very
significant successes we're having with
respect to surgery in our Province as
well starting this week on January 9th
as I as I informed you last Friday five
the five Health authorities and the pH
at Regional Health authorities and the
phsa have reactivated Emergency
Operations centers throughout the
province to provide enhanced supports
for staff and patients at 20 of our
hospitals this proactive test step is
taken to ensure patients continue to
have access to the hospital care
services they need in these challenging
times of respiratory illness and other
things facing our health care System
more people in a hospital Flex obviously
more people with severe illness in the
community
the health authorities have already set
up we're already set up to launch into
actions that will best need the patients
needs of patients in their regions most
of them have scheduled dedicated
leadership teams as well as adding ICU
Physicians hospitalists patient care
coordinators to be present seven days a
week the EEOC teams are focused on
reviewing hospital bed availability
identifying solutions to use emergency
department congestion and supporting
patients who are ready to be discharged
from hospital helping them to transition
in a safe way
they're working on key actions to
increase efficiency such as improving
the triage process in emergency
departments further implementing quick
response teams to connect patients with
care in the community increasing the
integration with urgent and Primary Care
Centers supporting Rural and remote care
and transport and improving
Communications about services for
patients we're also expanding continuing
to expand the capacity for long-term
care beds and opening transitional bids
for an alternate level of care patients
people who are still in the hospital
that are essentially their needs will be
better served in long-term care this is
the first week of operation already a
tremendous amount of work has been done
and I sincerely thank everyone involved
our extraordinary Health Care
Professionals and workers for their
efforts and because we're in the first
couple of weeks of January which is
typically when we observe our census in
hospitals closely we expect they'll be
continued fluctuation in the numbers as
we move forward
I wanted to give you an update on those
numbers last week when I was here I
reported on ten thousand two hundred and
twenty six people hospitalized in BC as
of yesterday at midnight end of day
yesterday that number was ten thousand
one hundred and sixteen needed a
hospital bed this represents about 87
occupancy rate of the total base and
surge bet but as you will know also 110
percent of Base bed capacity in the
province
this is obviously the week when we see
our highest census but we also saw
significantly higher census than we
typically see in the week between
Christmas and New Year's with emergency
operation centers in place in the return
of health care workers after the holiday
we are we are also able to see more
availability and ability for patients to
go to urgent Primary Care Centers into
their Primary Care Providers but our
hospitals are busy even historically
busy and people can be assured
spite of those circumstances when they
need hospital care they will receive it
I wanted to give you an update on
surgeries and in the questions I'll be
happy to also report on specific actions
taken in specific regions but we want to
obviously get
to questions today more quickly further
many of you and there's interest I think
in people in media for their communities
we'll be providing once a week on
Thursday per Hospital data so we're
providing it today per hospital later
today what the data is number of beds
number of people in hospital each of our
hospitals MBC and then we're providing
it after that every Thursday so you'll
have that detailed information on the
consistent basis I want to give you an
update on surgeries over the week from
December 18th to December 24th which is
typically a slow week Health authorities
perform 4
698 surgeries in BC just to put that in
context during the same week in 2019 and
there and there is an influence of
statutory holidays here before the
pandemic the number of surgeries
performed over 2000 it was
2574 so that's a significant and
historic number of surgeries completed e
even as the health system faces these
challenges but I would add the previous
week December 11th to 17th Health
theories completed
7463 surgeries in a time when many of
you and many people were reporting the
challenges of the Health Care System we
are completing more surgeries than in
any week at any time in the history of
the Health Care system in British
Columbia and the previous week to that
it was 7 343 that's the week of December
4th to 10th that's the fourth hottest in
the history of the BC Health Care System
breaking the records we set in October
what that suggests and says is that
extraordinary work is being done by our
healthcare workers and Healthcare
professionals and our system on the
issue of surgeries because of the
efforts we've collectively made all of
us with respect to surgical renewals
have helped people get the surgery they
need when they need it I also want to
say because we do postpone surgery so in
the context of that record number of
surgeries some surgeries were postponed
and from January 1st to January 7th and
this reflects situations in particular
hospitals Health authorities postponed
190 non-urgent scheduled surgeries
that's 116 in Fraser Health 26 in
Interior Health 23 in Island Health two
in Northern Health 18 in Vancouver
Coastal Health five in the provincial
Health Services authorities and that
includes two hvc children's hospitals
and three at BC women's hospitals as
we've noted in the past we've moved very
quickly in a very significant number of
those surgeries will be rescheduled and
done very soon as you know when we
cancel tens of thousands of surgeries
earlier in the pandemic 99 of those have
been completed and the our eocs are
there to support surgeries to continue I
also want to just note finally all of
the efforts and acknowledge the really
remarkable job our Pharmacy sector has
played and our Public Health sector in
providing people with vaccinations I
just want to put it in context
we have uh now a total doses
administered in terms of influenza is
one million 722
583 as of January 12th that is an
all-time record in BC and that effort
includes 35 percent of those age six to
six months to five years or four years
and 364 days and that is a significant
increase from where we were when we made
the appeal to people to get vaccinated
and have their children and bring their
children to be vaccinated early in
December I think it was 22 in that
category at that time it's now 35
percent this is a significant African
achievement there are appointments
available everywhere I encourage people
to continue to get vaccinated against
influenza continue to get vaccinated
because covid-19 but I want to
particularly recognize the role of
Pharmacy in our fall campaigns as
they've completed 2 million 287 000
vaccinations of covid-19 at Pharmacy
covid-19 or influenza which is an
enormous contribution and as all of you
know because almost many of you here
will have been vaccinated we do those
one at a time so that's a real
achievement for everyone in the Health
Care System we want to thank everybody I
think it's critical to to remember in
closing that all of us have continued to
have a role in play as Dr Henry has said
it's important to stay home when we're
sick and that's why we have the first
legislative sick days in our Province
it's important to wash our hands
frequently and get the the booster you
need for covet 19. a a flu shot as well
when you're eligible we need to keep
doing what we know and keep doing what
we know works and with that I invite Dr
Henry back to the podium we're happy to
take your questions
thank you after three years we finally
have a nice food here
thank you as a reminder to report to see
the phone uh please bear star one to
enter the queue you are limited to one
question in one follow-up please also
remember to take your phone off mute you
are not audible until your name is
called
our first question
is from Katie darraza vancouverson
this is my question um I'm just asking I
want to ask about Bill 36 because some
Physicians have expressed concerns about
what they say is government overreach so
uh they've expressed concerns about
government having more access to their
medical records or more power to meet
out more severe discipline against
Physicians what do you say to these
concerns
uh thanks very much for the the question
the opportunity to to respond on this
question
um and I'll give a slightly longer
answer but if you want more Kitty I'm
happy to give you a call later because
uh there'll be other questions as well I
know uh Bill 36 is the First Reform of
the Health Professions act in 30 years
considering the changes in health care
in that time it's a it's a timely and
important reform it came out out of uh a
very significant report done by a uh an
expert in the field Harry Caton that was
done in response to concerns about
certain Health regulatory bodies or one
the
dental profession and how it was
conducting certain aspects of his
business and a broader review of how we
regulated
um Health Professions we followed that
up with an all-party process in other
words the liberal Health critic of the
time the green party Health critic and I
reviewed the Caton report and developed
a series of recommendations which became
Bill 36 we had an extensive public
consultation one of the most expensive
extensive on legislation the problems
has ever seen thousands of participants
the majority of them health
professionals including of course many
doctors many others as well the
legislation does important things it
takes a proactive approach to
eliminating discrimination in BC's
Health System the in-plane site report
and the reconciliation act happened in
the middle of our consultations around
Bill 36. we improved governance we've
reduced the number of regulatory college
so they all have the ability to I think
do what they're required to do under the
law more easily when I became minister
of Health there was a regulatory college
that had to support
all of the activities of Regulation with
87 providers and so we are shifting that
that's our expectation there'll be six
colleges at the end of this process and
more transparency and accountability
something the public had been asking for
and many journalists such as yourself
had been asking for in other words not
when there are complaints made but when
there are findings of misconduct that
those findings of misconduct be
published and that is a reasonable step
that was massively supported in our
consultation so I'll speak to a couple
of the issues you raised that are issues
of concern that have been raised in the
last couple of days first it talks about
that there's been concern about patient
clinical records that somehow this will
give somebody in government the chance
to seize or copy patients clinical
records this is not true it is false
Bill 36 does not allow the government to
copy or seize clinical records only an
independent investigator appointed by
independent registrar the request of the
investigation committee can do so when
there's a complaint for example a
complaint of abuse you have to be able
to review the evidence to provide to
determine the validity of that complaint
when a healthcare professional has a
complaint against them and it has
warranted an investigation therefore
it's a significant complaint the
investigator requires the ability to
search records act in the Public's
interest but is also subject to
restraints on how that information can
be used let me be very clear this is no
different than the circumstance in the
present act no different
um there has been concerns about
what patient Physicians and other health
professionals can say again there are
con with respect to putting forward
false information which sometimes
happens for example false information
about the effectiveness of certain
um of certain remedies there there is a
requirement to be truthful and
evidence-based now that is a
professional requirement that all will
and particular Physicians support and
that will continue to be the case this
isn't about a critical this is about
limiting critical or free speech in fact
it's what the legislation supports what
we do now you can't put out false
information and as a professional and I
don't think anybody really would be
concerned about that finally I just say
with respect to the way we appoint
people to regulatory colleges so we've
had 22 regulatory colleges when I became
minister of Health we produced that
number an Amalgamated number it's now
15. it'll eventually be six currently at
the discretion of the minister of Health
the minister of Health in the case
myself before it was Terry Lake
would Point fifty percent of the board
members
and the profession would elect at these
23 different colleges
their board members from the profession
now the these colleges do not represent
the profession they represent public
interest so they regulate the profession
so the recommendation that was
overwhelmingly supported in our
consultation was to move to a
merit-based system where you have the
superintendent who the superintendent
making recommendations on people who are
qualified to act on uh Health College
boards and that is the core of it so it
takes away discretion from the minister
of Health
because it goes through that process and
from the professions themselves who are
being regulated by that process this was
overwhelmingly supported by all three
political parties who took part by the
vast majority I think 92 percent of
people who took part in our consultation
and that's what the ACT reflects and I
think that
there can always be criticism and always
better ways to do things we started this
process in 2018
five-year process most significant
consultation indigenous consultation
reflecting the requirements the
reconciliation Act and the in-plane site
report it's a massive consultation of
health professional organizations
including all of the ones involved
reflected in the 22 existing colleges a
significant
consultation of the public and a
reflection of the views of many
including people in the media about
about removing some of the opaque
elements of the current act I want to
say to everybody though complaints don't
get made public it's only when
determinations of misconduct are made
that they should be made public and they
should be made public in every case and
that's and that's the determination
that's made but that's after a lengthy
process where all sides have the
opportunity to State their view so
that's the that's the bill it's a
significant bill it's all laid out in
the legislation much of a significant
portion that was in regulation is now in
legislation and I think it's a good
thing for people
Katie do you have a follow-up
would they be people in the industry
with knowledge of these of that
particular profession or would they be
anyone how do you select who's pointed
uh the expertise and has developed
independently so we appoint
um an oversight body to make sure
because we had 22 and out of six with
health regulatory bodies with too much
variety and standards and so on so this
will be a merit-based process expertise
in in regulation and understanding of
Regulation how to deal with complaint
process and to ensure that Justice is
brought to those processes not just for
health professionals but health
professionals and patients so that's the
reason we're doing it that way right now
we of course attempt to do that and and
I think do a relatively a very good job
in doing that but the discretion for
example in this process and the
recommendations and the fact that those
are recommendations will be public and
and right now half of the people are
appointed directly by me and while I
make I think we've done a good job and I
think previous ministers have done a
good job in appointing really good
people those boards this
professionalizes that process this
happens frequently with boards
everywhere and I think uh I think that's
a good thing
next question is from Richard susman
Global News
Dr Henry would you say that we are
beyond the peak now of blue season and
what are the expectations moving forward
in terms of what we can expect for flu
and RFC and covet one of the things you
mentioned when we were talking about
masking mandate is quote there are very
negative Health impacts as well can you
talk me through what you see as the
drawbacks of of the Mandate in terms of
health impact
sure so in in terms of of influenza
we have seen a very unusual season where
it's been compressed from what we
usually see over several months in
November December and we have seen a
decrease but as I mentioned it's been
H3N2 almost exclusively very little of
any other strain so we are watching
because we can see a surge of influenza
B often later in the season just the way
it circulates but influenza B tends to
have less severe illness in most people
and less of an impact so we are watching
for that over the next few weeks
um in terms of RSV I do expect it to
continue it's leveled off and we'll see
it coming down thankfully it's come down
in children and we're seeing it more in
some long-term care homes and in adults
right now so the normal trajectory for
RSV will it for it to fade away over the
next few weeks and with covid what we're
seeing is relatively steady and that's
the good basis of protection that we
have and so leading to your second
question when I talked about the
negative consequences it was all of the
measures that we had in place so Mass
mandates in all settings reducing of
gatherings you know closing of schools
things that had we know negative impacts
and if we look at at you know countries
like China where they had very very
intense and strong coveted zero measures
in place for a long time we see that
there were tremendous negative impacts
on people for a whole variety of reasons
and we saw some of that from The Limited
closures that we had in place here
mental health anxiety and we're still
seeing the replica the repercussions of
some of that in people who need
assistance in mental health issues in
particular so it wasn't masking by
itself that has that has the negative
consequences that I was referring to it
was the measures that were in place and
I think we need to be realistic and
recognize and we can look at China as a
good example of that that even with all
of those intense measures in place this
virus has changed so that it can spread
there's no way that we can stop a
hundred percent of infections with the
strains that we're seeing circulate and
we see that with influenza we see that
with RSV as well so we need to put it in
the context that we are in now where we
have this very high level of protection
because of the immunity that we have
from vaccination from previous actions
and the tools that we have that we can
use in on our individual way to fit them
into our lives as we're getting back to
doing the things that we need to do and
it is incredibly important for us to get
together to be together to go to work to
have those Gatherings to we're social
creatures and we know that there's
important emotional mental physical
health things that come with us being
together and so we need to to take what
we have learned and put it in the
context of what we're doing in our lives
and our risk and do those risk
assessments for ourselves and for the
people around us and that's what we need
to do to get us through this respiratory
season and we need to learn these things
for the future as well
did you have a follow-up Richard
with a shortage in our Health Care
system in terms of Staff we've seen over
the last little bit increase in terms of
the number of a very vocal minority
calling for you to make changes around
the vaccine mandate for health care
workers in the hospital system is there
any consideration that would be given to
that and to that point is the
requirement now true vaccinations of a
coveted vaccine and
is that not offer in essence the same
amount of protection at this point
considering that second shot could have
been a year plus ago as being
unvaccinated would there be a
consideration giving to ensure that
those working in the healthcare system
are up to date on their boosters uh as
well
the the short answer is is no we're not
contemplating changes to the
requirements of vaccination in our
health care System you know the small
number of people who chose not to be
vaccinated
um you know have have not been in the
system for some time and we know how
important it is to have that protection
individually but also collectively
around supporting each other in the
Health Care system
so we are looking at moving away from
that being an order under a public
health or provincial Health officer
order to that being part of our our
routine regulations around people who
are working in our Health Care system
and it is what we as healthcare workers
are committed to doing everything
possible so that we stay healthy and
that we are able to to protect our
patients as best we can
in terms of the the the concept of
immunity what what the requirement is
and will continue to be is a primary
Series so whatever that primary series
is and for most people that's two doses
of vaccine
as we know after the primary series
things have become complicated and
that's because the virus has changed we
know that we have a high level of people
who've had mostly mild thankfully
infections from from Omicron over the
last little while so it is we have
various different types of immunity in
different people so it's not as simple
as saying you need to be up to date with
you need to have a booster because it
may be that people have had their
primary series they've had an infection
that gives them some hybrid immunity and
we know that now we're learning as we go
along that that gives a longer term
protection we know from our serology
that many people have a combination of
both vaccine-induced protection as well
as infection induced protection and so
it's very it's much more difficult to to
put in a place a standard that says You
must have this so it is a combination of
those things but overall all of the day
data that we have shows that if you have
at least that primary Series in the
context that we're in right now your
risk of having severe illness your risk
of being hospitalized is considerably
less it was four to eight fold less than
people who have not had any vaccines at
all so it still is an incredibly
important measure and it's important
where we need it most in our health care
System
next question is from Wolf debtor black
price
yeah hi good afternoon thank you for
taking my question much appreciated a
question uh to the minister
um what if any timelines do you have in
place to help bring down some of these
capacity numbers that that you mentioned
earlier
um are you looking at reducing figures
within two weeks within a month uh what
if any sort of internal deadlines have
you sort of set yourself for that well
the Emergency Operations Center will be
in place for six weeks
that doesn't mean it will take six weeks
we would hope to see fewer people in our
census numbers in the hospital but
um just be clear what we're trying to do
we're trying to ensure that patient flow
is there and supports are there for our
health care workers our Healthcare teams
of workers and professionals and for
patients to ensure that they get care at
this critical moment there's a lot of
people in hospital this is historically
high level of people in our hospitals
that was true between Christmas and New
Year's and compared to other seasons and
it's true now but what we don't want to
do and what we want to avoid what we
want to continue to do is do high
numbers of surgeries so we're providing
care because if you defer treatments for
any reason then you have to make that up
later for the system but for people it's
very hard when you defer surgery so we
did defer some surgeries this week in
particular location we also did an
extraordinary number of historically
High number of surgeries so what we want
to do is continue to provide the care
people need in the problem and take down
we hope over this period the number of
people in hospitals a lot of that those
related to I mean we always get
questions about
about covid-19 Dr Henry just talked
about the requirement to be vaccinated
the issue isn't requirements the issue
is covet 19. the issue is respiratory
illness or issue is that there are a
number of people who need care and so
what those High numbers reflect is the
extraordinary work of healthcare workers
and Health Care Professionals and
providing unprecedented amount of care
we're doing vastly more surgeries than
ever before I argument vastly more
diagnostic tests more primary care
business treating more people in a
hospital between more people in our ERS
and after three years of a pandemic and
it's getting on to three years now our
health care teams in spite of the
constant pressure that's existed no High
season and low season just constant High
season of pressure there's been a lot of
pressure on all of them so we're trying
to do everything we can in this period
to deal that and support it what the
eeocs will be in place for six weeks
of did you ever fall off
yes it's the system is under such high
pressure as you say why not take and
destroys a little bit early but why not
take uh or more precautionary measures
um obviously as we heard earlier
um 100 transformation or preventing 100
of transmission
is not possible but why not aim for 90
why why make 100 uh 100 uh the
thresholds run uh say 90 is available uh
any one one could argue that any that
any amount could make a difference on
the Healthcare System Christmas trend
yeah so I think you have to put it in
the context of where we are so we do
have the best protection that we have
through vaccination that level of
immunity in our communities is that
buffer that means that covet is not
causing any more severe illness than
other respiratory infections and so to
try and and
incrementally reduce Transmissions above
that we would have to take additional
measures that would impact people's
ability to do important things in their
lives so we would have to stop large
groups stop large Gatherings reduce the
numbers of people who get together
restrict travel all of those things that
have negative impacts on people's Health
as well so there's no one simple thing
so everybody wearing masks is not going
to make a tremendous difference in the
transmission of these viruses because we
transmit them in those situations when
we're at home when with with when we're
with friends when we're doing social
things that are important in our lives
where we don't wear masks and it still
allows allows these viruses to transmit
so the most important thing that we can
do as a community and people in BC have
done this is to get vaccinated to get
that protection that gives that level of
buffer the best that we can do and then
to each of us take our own
responsibility for
protecting others we're staying away
from others if we're sick if we are
having mild symptoms we need to be
around others wear a mask and those of
us who are most at risk we can do extra
protections ourselves by avoiding going
to certain situations if we can by
wearing a well-fitting mask or
respirator if we have to be in those
more risky situations and this is this
is how we manage respiratory Seasons
before and now covet has added to that
it's another virus that we have to deal
with and we are in a very different
situation and you know it would be nice
it would be really nice if there was
just one simple measure that was going
to make that difference but it's not
it's all that Collective things that we
are doing and continue to do a need to
continue to do together
next in the line is Lisa use the city
news 11 30.
we can expect next year to be an easier
season of respiratory illness like does
the um the the rough year this year and
kids catching up on catching these
illnesses is that Cortez of an easier
one next year does it take a while for
that Community
um I guess exposure to to gain again
I wish I could answer that question one
thing that I've learned in the face of
uh in the face of sarsko V2 is humility
because it changes
um however you know we have been
relatively
looking at the tea leaves and watching
what's happened over the last few months
things have have progressed as we kind
of thought they would and we're sort of
seeing less and less variation and
severity of illness so we need to keep
watching for that and yes I expect that
there will be some impact of the fact
that so many more children were exposed
to RSB so many more people were exposed
to to influenza but then again influenza
likes to change too so I can't really
say I will say that we're watching
around the world we'll be watching what
happens in Australia New Zealand this
year but we do know that the most
most important thing that we can do is
keep our immunity up by getting boosters
when we need to by getting our flu shot
every year and so
um
I think we just need to keep on watching
and and we'll see what happens in the
next little while
Lisa did you have a follow-up
I do and just over the next I guess four
or five weeks when the eocs are going to
be open but over the next four or five
weeks what are your biggest what is the
biggest concern is it one virus more
than another is it overall I just
wondering what the biggest story
you know I think it's not one virus over
the other I think we need to pay
attention to all of them
um and as I was talking about today you
know there's these many different things
that we watch over time to see if things
are going up or down or staying the same
and and then we add in that whole genome
sequencing to see if there's something
new or different and
um every time there's something new or
different we have new technology that
allows us to to say things about it and
so you know one of the reasons why
there's such a concern about the uh the
the the the
um
the what am I trying to say the the new
variants is that uh you know we do
things like neutralizing antibodies and
they're really easy to do and people say
oh it's more transmissible it binds
stronger
um but those are things that come out
first and then over time we we actually
put it in the context of everything else
so I I think it is all of these and for
me it's not just it's the fact that
respiratory season is here and it is
adding a burden to an already stretched
system as the minister was talking about
we've not had any down time it's been
high level through the summer and now in
respiratory season so it is part of what
is causing the strain on our system but
it's certainly not the only thing so
those two things are are together we're
seeing normally this time of year we
would see a lot of other reasons why
people start going into our hospitals
sometimes for delayed care sometimes
because of weather issues and we're also
seeing that on a base that's higher
higher than normal because we now have
covid we now have a new virus that's
added to our repertoire that we're going
to have to deal with for the next
foreseeable future
next question is Bruce T Basu Capital
daily
hi thank you for taking my question
um Dr Henry you mentioned there's been a
surge in norovirus and gastrointestinal
issues in NBC
given studies that show that
gastrointestinal problems can be
symptoms of covid are people showing up
with GI issues at hospitals being tested
for covid
yes although the things that we see for
for covet tend to be quite different
norovirus is a very particular problem
and people are being tested for it and
it spreads very rapidly for anybody
who's had the experience of it so the
the clinical pattern of what we see with
uh norovirus for example is quite
different from what uh from some of the
GI symptoms that can present uh with
SARS cov2 as well so the short answer is
that they look different and they're
tested differently as well
priesty did you have a follow-up
yeah I think
[Music]
I think you see and also specifically in
Island Health
um and is is postponing surgery is the
reason why Hospital occupancy is dropped
by over 200 over the past week
well first of all it didn't drop by over
200 in the last week so that's not the
case it dropped by I think I think it
was about 120 and the answer is no we've
been doing more surgeries than ever
before and we're going to continue to
with our surgical renewal commitment we
put it in place by adding operation
Ingram nurses adding anesthesiologists
adding medical device reprocessing
technicians and so that's the reason we
did all of those things I listed off the
numbers from the December 1st to 7th but
what we do is under different
circumstances surgeries can be postponed
for example a team of people that's
performing the surgery
test positive for influenza or covid-19
the surgery and that slate of surgeries
would have to be postponed and there is
of course more illness in the system but
in a general sense and we provided the
information for January 1st the 7th and
we'll provide the situation the the the
analysis of this week and next week in
terms of surgeries postponed number of
surgeries postponed is relatively low as
compared to the very significant number
of surgeries taking place the record
number of surgeries taking place so no
it's true that if we decided to have
more people wait for their surgeries we
would we might bring down somewhat the
number of uh people in hospitals but
that would also have a profound effect
on all those people we are very
reluctant
to delay surgeries and that's the reason
we continue to do record numbers of
surgeries December was an extraordinary
achievement by our surgeons our nurses
and our Health Sciences professionals
our health care workers and I think
everyone should acknowledge that I don't
think anywhere else in Canada maybe in
the world we see in such a difficult
time such an extraordinary performance
it's one part of what we do in the
Health Care system final thing I'd say
is that surgeries themselves there it
would only affect the number of what
we'd call non-urgent surgeries that
require overnight stays so that's not
the reason why we've seen a decline but
what I would say about the numbers is
that there's a decline of about a
hundred from where we were last week
it's still dramatically High we still
have hospitals in BC notably in Kelowna
and Kamloops in Richmond and in other
communities in Burnaby and communities
in BC that are above Basin surge beds
capacity which is and our teams are
doing an exceptional job managing that
that situation so I wouldn't say that
the number of people in hospitals today
is a low number it's a historically High
number it's just slightly lower than it
was last week
and last question from Benoit ferradini
CBC Radio Canada
thank you for taking my question and the
first one will be about the Pax lovid
drug I'd like to know how much of the
stock of those uh doses of drugs have
been used in BC so far it is still
around 16 persons and what are your
thoughts about letting it being
prescribed by pharmacists as it's the
case in other provinces if possible I
like to have things or in English and
French
sure so we we have a clinical care
committee that provides the guidelines
on on use of of medications like
paxlovid particularly as the evidence
around its use was was increasing and as
you know early on we had limited amounts
of it so it was available only in
specific centers and we put in place a
centralized process for people who
didn't have a physician to be able to
get access to it if they needed it we've
now expanded that quite a bit since
about the summer I don't have the exact
numbers of doses that have been used but
I know that it is much more available
people are do have access to it much
more widely it can be prescribed by any
physician and it's available in
pharmacies across the province and we
still have in place the centralized
intake Center where you can talk to a
pharmacist about whether it is a
medication that is compatible with the
with the medication drawer on in your
health condition
is a challenging drug because it does
have many what we call drug drug
interactions and people with certain
conditions particularly
depending on their renal or kidney
function and liver function aren't able
to take it necessarily so the data that
I know is that about half of people who
are assessed for it who might have
access to might benefit from paxilovid
are not able to take it in discussions
with their clinician because of the
medications their honored because of
their health condition
in terms of
Pharmacy prescribing I understand
Ontario just started that are
relatively recently what we have in
place here is still that it is
prescribed by a nurse practitioner or
physician but it's available through
pharmacies and we have Pharmacy consults
to help help people who don't have a
primary care practitioner have access to
the the medication as well
but we'll do all the French at the end
okay Minister Dix will do all the French
in the end at the end uh Benoit do you
have a follow-up
the follow-up will be foreign
Peak is behind us what is the forecast
for the next week's month about how the
hospital will keep busy and how long
will we need the EOC uh you know staying
active
yeah so I'll just talk to the influenza
piece whereas the first Peak and so we
still need to pay attention to influenza
because we know that uh we we often see
influenza B start to circulate around
this time so we're watching for that
um and uh so it is one of the pieces
that adds to the burden of of people who
need hospital care it's also something
that affects long-term care homes in
particular we know influenza can be very
severe cause very severe illness in
long-term care homes and we're seeing
outbreaks in long-term care from
influenza also settle down so that's
good news in the short term I'll let you
talk to the impact
and and let's just say in English just
because it's it's uh it may have reached
its peak and we'll see I mean we we
um we learn about these circumstances
every day it's still significant in the
system I mean
um I think people would understand that
even if it's we'll say 374 last week and
that's 320 or something this week 320 is
still a significant number equally for
RSV influenza has gone down in the
system so
um you asked how long the eocs will be
in place six weeks to ensure that we're
managing the system through this time
and we're doing the maximum we can to
help people and get them the care that
they need well you'll note last January
and and at previous times early in the
pandemic particularly we delayed
non-urgent scheduled surgeries and we do
that in individual cases now and I laid
off the numbers and
just in response to the previous
question that was 23 last week in
Vancouver Island Health Authority in
total
and and so we're we're doing that but
we're trying to maintain a maximum
response because we know people
who need surgery need surgery as much in
January as any other time we want to
deliver that so that practice that we
engaged initially to defer all
non-urgent surgeries has now been
significantly adjusted and was during
both the Delta and the Omicron variant
of concern early I'm a chronic bearing
of concerns cases so we deferred fewer
surgeries in those times and now we're
actually and have done in December with
all of this going on had the most
extraordinary month of surgery we've
ever had in the province of BC and
that's a real tribute to all our
healthcare workers uh
[Music]
School Freeman Fanfare the necessities
I'm going to be making a report on our
early efforts to expand the scope of
practice of Pharmacists I talked a
little bit about vaccination but the
efforts so far have been extremely
successful and we're very positive about
what's happened and the work that
professions are all doing to provide
care to people across BC of course we'll
be adding to the that scope of practice
later this spring for uh for from
Pharmacy and from pharmacists but I
think it's fair to say that our
pharmacists have done X exceptional work
this fall both in supporting people and
getting the prescriptions they need and
in providing vaccinations thank you
that's all the time we have today thanks
for joining and have a good weekend